المباني ويمكنك أن ترى كيف
تدفع هذه الرياح كل هذا الدخان إلى
مستوى الشارع ، يمكنك رؤيته على
الجانب الأيسر من شاشتك ،
ولا يمكنك حتى رؤية الشارع
الذي ينفجر فيه هذا الدخان من تقاطع 116
و  بارك ، لذا فهذه هي الزاوية الشمالية الشرقية
من سنترال بارك ، يتم توجيهها
مباشرة نحو سنترال بارك ، يتم
تفجيرها في الاتجاه الجنوبي الغربي ، لذا إذا
كنت تعيش في تلك المنطقة ، فمن المحتمل أن تكون فكرة حكيمة
لإبقاء النوافذ
مغلقة بالتأكيد وربما البقاء في الداخل عند
التجويف إذا كان Con Ed
يتخذ العمال وإدارة الإطفاء الخطوات اللازمة لوضع
الأقنعة على الأرجح فكرة حكيمة ألا
تتنفس هذه الأشياء في الخارج ، وفي الوقت نفسه
نرى الدخان يستمر في الارتفاع ،
يبدو أن هذا المبنى قد انهار للتو
على نفسه وانهار في
الشارع وما حصلت عليه الآن  يكون